This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Millions of tweets are posted every day. Most of them get little attention, but there is one user whose tweets always make news. Ding, ding, ding, there's been a post-it tweet. The president is off and tweeting this morning. Just tweeted two minutes ago, yes, he said, I'm extremely pleased to see that CNN
这里是 Hidden Brain，我是香卡·维丹塔。每天都有数百万条推文发布。其中大多数受到的关注很少，但有一个用户的推文总能成为新闻。叮，叮，叮，有一条特朗普的推文发出去了。总统今天一早就开始发推了。就在两分钟前刚刚发了一条，是的，他说，我极其高兴地看到 CNN
has finally been exposed as fake news and garbage journalism. It's about time. From Tweeted Quote, the United States has foolishly given Pakistan more than $33 billion in aid over the last 15 years, and they have given us nothing but lies and to see thinking of our leaders as people. This is not an episode about Donald Trump. It's an episode about an emotion that predates him, but that he has taken to an extreme. We now hear this emotion in the way we talk about a broad range of topics. The emotion is outrage. With a stench of blatant bias and hurt to stick around in the rough of pro-war,
终于被揭露为假新闻和垃圾新闻。真是大快人心。根据推特引述，在过去的 15 年里，美国愚蠢地向巴基斯坦提供了超过 33]]> 亿美元的援助，而他们给我们的除了谎言和欺骗什么都没有，把我们的领导人当成白痴。这不是一集关于唐纳德·特朗普的节目。这是一集关于一种比他更古老的情绪的节目，但他把这种情绪推向了极致。我们现在在讨论广泛的话题时，都能听到这种情绪。这种情绪就是愤怒。带着赤裸裸的偏见的恶臭，以及对亲战分子的伤害，
it's embarrassing to humiliate the American Americans and allow us to this time. Vicious, the way she said it, vicious, f-word. That's not somebody that has the heart of these psychotic Democrats to let the president the media mind. Sad, sad we're toys will happen to me. I'm a seller. You are a seller. Just like the president, many Americans have come to believe that the only way to
羞辱美国人，让我们在这个时候感到尴尬。恶毒，她说话的方式，恶毒，F开头的脏话。那根本不是一个拥有这些精神错乱的民主党人的心胸的人，他们让总统和媒体操碎了心。悲哀，悲哀，我们要遭遇不测了。我是个卖家。你是个卖家。就像总统一样，许多美国人开始相信，促成改变的唯一方法
spur change is by jinnying up anger. It isn't enough to say your opponents are wrong, you have to say they are reprehensible. This can be for big issues like immigration and healthcare, it can be for smaller issues, like the new album by Taylor Swift or the popularity of pumpkin spice. Is all this outrage effective? Well, yes. For every moral, emotional word that people use in a tweet, we found that it increased the rate of retweeting from other people who saw it by 15 to 20%.
就是煽动愤怒。仅仅说你的对手错了是不够的，你还得说他们罪大恶极。这可以针对移民和医疗保健等重大问题，也可以针对泰勒·斯威夫特的新专辑或南瓜香料的流行等较小的问题。所有这些愤怒真的有效吗？嗯，是的。我们发现，人们在推文中使用的每一个带有道德和情感色彩的词，都会使看到它的其他人转发的速度提高 15% 到 20%。
But it comes at a cost. Outrage now leaps from our social media feeds and television screens to PTA meetings and family reunions. Many people feel overwhelmed by the shouting and disengage. Others are so consumed with fury that they become. I'm going to be a big one. I know, I know what you're doing. I know what you're doing. I know what you're doing. I know what you're doing. I know what you're doing. Saturday, January 19th, 2019. Julie Zimmerman checked Twitter and saw something that made her upset.
但这需要付出代价。愤怒现在从我们的社交媒体动态和电视屏幕跃升至 PTA（家长教师联合会）会议和家庭聚会。许多人感到被喊叫声压得喘不过气来，从而选择退缩。另一些人则被狂怒吞噬，以至于他们变成了……我知道，我知道你在干什么。我知道你在干什么。我知道你在干什么。我知道你在干什么。我知道你在干什么。2019 年 1 月 19 日，星期六。朱莉·齐默尔曼查看推特时，看到了一些让她心烦意乱的东西。
It was a video filmed hundreds of miles from her home in Ohio at the National Mall in Washington, DC. There was this old or native American man and these kids surrounded him and were yelling things at him and laughing at him. And as they were blocking his path, he apparently was trying to walk over to believe him a memorial or something like that and they wouldn't let them through. The kids surrounding this man look like 15-year-old boys. They were nearly all white. A few were making gestures that look like Tomahawk chops. Some wore hats that red. Make America great again.
那是一段在华盛顿特区国家广场拍摄的视频，拍摄地点距离她在俄亥俄州的家有数百英里远。有一个老年美洲原住民男子，周围围着一些孩子，他们对他大喊大叫，嘲笑他。当他们挡住他的去路时，他显然正试图走到某个地方去，比如去一个纪念碑之类的地方，而他们不让他们过去。围着这个男子的孩子看起来像是 15 岁的男孩。他们几乎全是白人。有几个人做出了看起来像战斧切砍的手势。有些人戴着写着“让美国再次伟大”的帽子。
These kids were making fun of this guy because he was Native American because he had a drum and was chanting something unfamiliar to them. It was it was pretty cringeworthy. We're going to look at Julie's encounter with a story in some detail because it's revealing about how outrage works today. Like many others watching that day, Julie fixated on one boy in the video. He was standing directly in front of the Native American man, staring at him. He had what looked like a smirk on his face, as the older man sang. His image evoked all the horrifying things Americans have done to Native Americans throughout the centuries.
这些孩子取笑这个家伙，因为他是美洲原住民，因为他拿着一个鼓，并且在唱着他们不熟悉的歌词。这真的很让人尴尬。我们将详细探讨朱莉对这个故事的遭遇，因为这揭示了今天的愤怒是如何运作的。和那天观看视频的许多其他人一样，朱莉盯着视频中的一个男孩不放。他正站在美洲原住民男子正前方，盯着他看。当这位老者唱歌时，他脸上带着一种幸灾乐祸的笑容。他的形象唤起了几个世纪以来美国人对美洲原住民做过的所有可怕的事情。
As the day went on, more details emerged. The boys were students at Covington Catholic High School in Kentucky just across the river from Cincinnati where Julie lives. I started seeing tweets that the kids were chanting, build the wall, build that wall. Julie's son was around the same age as the kids in the video and he also went to a Catholic school. Julie texted him. I said, you know, if I ever caught you acting that way, I mean, I'd be horrified. By the evening, now to the outrage over a video showing the story was everywhere. Now it's likely that you've seen this video
随着时间的推移，更多的细节浮出水面。这些男孩是肯塔基州卡文顿天主教高中的学生，该学校位于辛辛那提河对岸，朱莉就住在辛辛那提。我开始看到推文说这些孩子们在喊“筑起高墙，筑起那堵墙”。朱莉的儿子和视频中的孩子差不多大，他也读天主教学校。朱莉给他发了短信。我说，你知道，如果我抓到你做出那种行为，我的意思是，我会吓坏的。到了晚上，对一段展现这一故事的视频的愤怒已经无处不在。现在，你很可能已经看过这个视频了
probably seen it by now. The viral video sweeping the internet of a mob of mega hat wearing high school students troubling scene many are calling racist played out in Washington yesterday on the steps of the Lincoln we leave these boys are not getting a good education because it makes little sense to angrily chant build the wall to a population with literally zero illegal immigrants who were here long before we were. I talked to a friend of mine who lives in New York, a former roommate of mine, and she said her yoga teacher called and said, let's drive to that school in Kentucky and protest.
你现在可能已经看过了。这段在互联网上疯靡的病毒式视频显示，一群戴着红帽子的高中生卷入了一场令人不安的场景，许多人称之为种族主义事件，昨天在华盛顿林肯纪念堂的台阶上上演。这些男孩没有接受过良好的教育，因为对一个基本上没有非法移民、而且在很久以前就来到这里的人群愤怒地喊着“筑起高墙”，这是毫无意义的。我和一个住在纽约的朋友谈过，她是我以前的室友，她说她的瑜伽老师打电话说，让我们开车去肯塔基的那所学校抗议吧。
That's the sort of level of reaction people were having to this. Like this yoga teacher in New York wanted to hop in the car and drive 10 hours to protest in front of the school. While Julie's friends were texting her messages of outrage, her son was having very different conversations about the same video.
人们对这件事的反应就是这种级别的。就像纽约这位瑜伽老师想跳上车，开车 10 个小时去那所学校前抗议一样。当朱莉的朋友们给她发来充满愤怒的短信时，她的儿子正在就同一段视频进行完全不同的对话。
His friends had started texting him at some point on Saturday saying, you know, I think that these guys are getting a bum rap. I don't think they're guilty of what they're being accused of. being accused of. Sunday, January 20, 2019. In the late morning, after church, Julie checked Twitter. She saw that someone had uploaded a nearly two-hour long video, which showed much more of the confrontation between the Catholic school students and the Native American man. I started watching because I wanted to show my son where the kids had been chanting
周六的某个时候，他的朋友开始给他发短信说，你知道，我觉得这些家伙受到了不公正的指责。我不认为他们有他们被指控的那种罪行。被指控。2019 年 1 月 20 日，星期日。深夜上午，做完礼拜后，朱莉查看了推特。她看到有人上传了一段将近两小时的视频，其中展示了天主教学校学生与美洲原住民男子之间冲突的更多画面。我开始观看，是因为我想向我的儿子展示孩子们在哪里喊着
Bill DeWal. He challenged me on that point, and I watched the Hour Plus video of the incident, and I couldn't find anywhere where they had been chanting that. And that wasn't all. This is what the longer video Day. The mall was packed. There was a group called the Black Hebrew Israelites. And they were yelling vile things at the kids. A bunch of babies made out of insects. Right, try the problem, baby. This is what America makes.
筑起高墙。他在这点上反驳了我，我看了那个长达一个多小时的事件视频，却找不到任何他们曾这样高喊的地方。不仅如此。长视频显示的情况是这样的。广场上挤满了人。有一个名为“黑人希伯来以色列人”的群体。他们对孩子们大喊大叫一些极其恶劣的话。一堆昆虫变成的婴儿。没错，尝尝这个麻烦，宝贝。这就是美国制造的。
To make America great looks like. You know, somebody yelling something, something that you doesn't give you justification to yell anything back, but I thought that set a tone that these kids, some of whom may have never been in a situation like this, might have been feeling nervous or attacked or I don't know it, the insults being yelled by the Black Hebrew Israelites definitely altered my understanding of what happened next. The indigenous people's march was also taking place in DC that day. Nathan Phillips was the older man in the original viral video. I saw Phillips walk over to the kids on this longer video and remember the original video
让美国变得伟大的样子。你知道，有人在大喊大叫，你不能因为别人喊了什么就觉得有正当理由回骂，但我认为这定下了一个基调，即这些孩子中有些人可能从未经历过这样的情况，可能会感到紧张或受到攻击，我不知道，黑人希伯来以色列人大喊的侮辱性言论绝对改变了我对接下来发生事情的理解。那天，土著人民游行也在华盛顿特区举行。内森·菲利普斯是最初病毒视频中的那位老者。我看到菲利普斯在这段较长的视频中走向孩子们，还记得最初的视频
had just shown Phillips surrounded by these kids and the extrapolation originally was that these kids had walked up to Phillips and surrounded him and blocked his path and not allowed him to pass. Well, as you watch the longer video, you see Phillips and an entourage. I mean, there were a lot of people with Phillips all walking over to talk to the kids. So, Phillips had not been trying to get somewhere and these kids blocked him. He actually went up and initiated the interaction with the kids. And what were the kids doing? What were they chanting? What were they shouting?
只显示菲利普斯被这些孩子包围，最初的推断是这些孩子走到菲利普斯身边包围了他，挡住了他的去路，不让他通过。嗯，当你观看较长的视频时，你会看到菲利普斯和一群随从。我的意思是，有很多人和菲利普斯一起走过去和孩子们说话。所以，菲利普斯并不是想去某个地方却被这些孩子们挡住了。他实际上是主动走过去并开启了与孩子们的互动。那孩子们在做什么？他们在喊什么？他们在叫什么？
Some of them were trying to make their friends laugh. Some of them were being offensive. I think doing a Tomahawk chop is an offensive thing to do. And the student who was smarting at Nathan Phillips? He was laughing for a while and then they kind of locked eyes. And I don't know what he was thinking. I don't know if he was feeling, but I've seen that look on teenagers where you've
他们中的一些人试图逗朋友笑。他们中的一些人具有冒犯性。我认为做战斧切砍手势是一件具有冒犯性的事。而那个在内森·菲利普斯面前假笑的学生呢？他先是笑了一会儿，然后他们四目相对。我不知道他在想什么。我不知道他当时是什么感觉，但我见过青少年身上那种
got waves of thoughts passing through your head and your underlying thinking is what what I do I don't know what to do you know he looked nervous to me Julie had seen the smirking boy as emblematic of the terrible things down to Native Americans. Now she saw a teenager who was trying hard not to show his friends that he was nervous. On social and broadcast media, the outrage flipped. If you were left leaning, you were outraged by these kids originally. If you were conservative, you just put your head under a rock because even you couldn't defend what you originally saw.
脑海中闪过层层思绪，而你内心深处的想法是“我做了什么，我不知道该怎么做”的神情，你知道的，他看起来很紧张。朱莉曾经把那个假笑的男孩视为对美洲原住民做过的可怕事情的象征。现在，她看到的是一个竭力不在朋友面前表现出自己很紧张的青少年。在社交媒体和广播电视上，愤怒的情绪反转了。如果你倾向于左翼，你最初会对这些孩子们感到愤怒。如果你是保守派，你只会把头埋进沙子里，因为连你也无法为自己最初看到的一幕辩护。
Then there was a reaction to it where a lot of conservatives after they had seen the longer videos started defending these kids and what was interesting to me was how difficult it was for people to change their original take on it. I was afraid to tell a few people initially that I had changed my mind about the coming and gathlet thing,
然后出现了一种反弹，许多保守派在看过较长的视频后开始为这些孩子辩护，而对我来说有趣的是，人们改变对这件事最初看法是多么困难。我一开始甚至不敢告诉某些人，我已经改变了对卡文顿天主教事件的看法，
which is crazy. Like, why can't you just say, you know, I think it was wrong about this, but I knew some people would be upset because it's as though you're giving your enemy ammunition by admitting that they might be right and you might have been wrong and you can't ever show weakness or admit that maybe the other side has a point. Julie told a friend about her change of heart, and her friend encouraged her to write an essay about it.
这太疯狂了。就像，为什么你不能直接说，你知道，我觉得我之前在这个事上弄错了，但我知道有些人会很不高兴，因为这就好像你承认他们可能是对的而你可能是错的，是在给你的敌人递子弹，你永远不能表现出软弱或承认对方可能有道理。朱莉向一位朋友讲述了自己心态的转变，她的朋友鼓励她写一篇关于此事的文章。
And I wrote that essay probably in 15 minutes. I mean, it just spilled out. And I submitted it for publication, and it was published very quickly. The essay was published in The Atlantic. The headline read, I failed the Covington Catholic Test. In the piece, Julie admitted she had been hasty and quick to judgment. Almost immediately after her essay was posted,
我大概在 15 分钟内就写好了那篇文章。我的意思是，它就像喷涌而出一样。我把它投给媒体发表，并且很快就发表了。这篇文章发表在《大西洋月刊》上。标题是：我没能通过卡文顿天主教学校的考验。在这篇文章中，朱莉承认自己当时过于草率和轻率地下了结论。几乎在她的文章发布后不久，
it prompted howls of outrage from the right. My essay was weaponized against liberals, against progressives. And I, you know, it made me uncomfortable to see that. Like, oh gosh, did I make a mistake here? My brother-in-law called my husband to say, Rush Limbaugh just mentioned your wife's name on the air. And I thought, oh gosh, what have I done? One of the drive-by media outlets that really roasted these kids from
它就引发了来自右翼的愤怒叫嚣。我的文章被武器化了，用来反对自由派、反对进步派。而我，你知道，看到这一点让我感到很不舒服。就像，天哪，我是不是在这里犯了个错误？我姐夫打电话给我丈夫说，拉什·林堡刚刚在节目里提到了你妻子的名字。我想，天哪，我都做了些什么？那些对来自
Covington was at the Atlantic. And a writer at the Atlantic has published a piece, I failed the Covington Catholic test. Next time there's a viral story, I'll wait for more facts to emerge. Julie Erwin Zimmerman. She was one of the early pilots on and she's begging for forgiveness. She failed the test. She went along with why does anybody in their right mind?
卡文顿的孩子们大加挞伐的泛滥媒体之一就是《大西洋月刊》。而《大西洋月刊》的一位作家发表了一篇文章《我没能通过卡文顿天主教学校的考验》。下次再有病毒式传播的故事时，我会等待更多事实浮出水面。朱莉·欧文·齐默尔曼。她是早期推波助澜者之一，现在却在乞求原谅。她没能通过考验。她随波逐流……为什么任何一个神智正常的人……
I know the temptation, but why isn't there even a moment's pause when anything from social media becomes source material in drive by media? It is a cesspool and everybody knows that it's a cesspool. Russia Limbo was wrong in several ways. Julie didn't work at the Atlantic and had nothing to do with their initial coverage. And she was not an early pider on. Before she wrote her essay, she herself had posted nothing on social media about the comington Catholic students. In addition, lots of journalists had in fact covered the story with nuance. Ironically, Rush Limbaugh was doing exactly what Julie had initially done.
我知道那种诱惑，但当社交媒体上的任何内容成为泛滥媒体的素材时，为什么连一秒钟的暂停都没有？这是一个粪坑，每个人都知道这是一个粪坑。拉什·林堡在几个方面都错了。朱莉并不在《大西洋月刊》工作，也与他们最初的报道没有任何关系。而且她也并非早期的推波助澜者。在她写那篇文章之前，她自己并没有在社交媒体上发布任何关于卡文顿天主教学生的言论。此外，事实上有很多记者带着细致入微的视角报道了这个故事。讽刺的是，拉什·林堡所做的正是朱莉最初做过的事。
He was leaping to sweeping conclusions about liberals, about Julie, about journalists, with very limited evidence. This is the way our cycles of outrage work. Each blast produces misstatements, exaggerations, and errors. These are then seized upon by the other side, which proceeds to produce its own mistatements, exaggerations and errors. The cycle feeds on itself. The outrage in the Covington Catalyst's Coles' candle is emblematic of our times.
他在证据非常有限的情况下，对自由派、对朱莉、对记者草率地下了宏大的结论。这就是我们的愤怒循环运作的方式。每一次爆发都会产生不实之词、夸大其词和错误。然后，这些会被另一方抓住，接着又产生他们自己的不实之词、夸大其词和错误。这个循环自我滋养。卡文顿天主教学生风波中的愤怒正是我们这个时代的象征。
Right-wing talk radio invented the modern art of the rant. Cable television pundits perfected it. Social media has made outrage part of daily discourse. Now, instead of a handful of screaming voices on radio and TV, you have thousands of people on the right and the left and raged about politics and each other. Events that would never have been considered new stories now dominate the headlines. Julie used to be a reporter and editorial writer at the Cincinnati Enquara. If you were my editor and I came to you and said, yeah, this Native American guy and these kids and mega hats
右翼脱口秀广播发明了现代咆哮艺术。有线电视名嘴将其臻于完善。社交媒体使愤怒成为了日常话语的一部分。现在，广播和电视上不再只有少数尖叫的声音，右翼和左翼有成千上万的人对政治和彼此愤怒不已。那些本绝不会被视为新闻故事的事件现在却占据了头条新闻。朱莉曾是《辛辛那提问询报》的记者和社论作家。如果你是我的编辑，而我找到你说：“嘿，今天这个美洲原住民大叔和这些戴着红帽子的孩子们在广场上陷入了一种紧张的对峙，我觉得这是一个新闻。”
kind of got in this tense standoff on the mall today. And I think it's a story. Any self-respecting editor would say, you know, did somebody get shot? You know, how is this a story? This weird confrontations between people happen all the time and we don't consider them to be news stories. But the ground rules have changed. All of a sudden, there are powerful incentives to be fastest to react and loudest to shout. People are falling all over each other to
任何一个有自尊心的编辑都会说：“你知道的，有人中枪了吗？这怎么能算是一个新闻？”这种人与人之间奇怪的对峙时有发生，我们并不认为它们是新闻故事。但基本规则已经变了。突然之间，成为反应最快、嗓门最大的人有着强烈的诱惑和激励。人们争先恐后地
be first in line to say how awful this was. You get to show how woke you are or how conservative you are without actually doing any work. You just look at something, you're retweeted, you try to make a really smart, funny comment that thousands of people will retweet, and then you kind of pat yourself on the back for being involved in the conversation,
排在第一个说这有多糟糕的行列中。你无需付出任何实际努力，就能展现出你的“觉醒”或保守。你只需看一眼某样东西，转发它，试着发表一个非常聪明、有趣的评论，让成千上万的人转发，然后你就可以为自己参与了这场对话而自我感觉良好，
but you have done nothing. Is Julie right? Is all this anger really accomplishing nothing? What researchers have found about the science of viral outrage when we come back. Cast your mind back to a party, one that happened a long, long time ago. Someone at this party does something bad. Maybe steal something. The group has to decide what to do with this law breaker. Do nothing and the transgressor might do bad stuff again. Better to punish it or cast him out. For the thousands of generations,
但你其实什么也没做。朱莉说得对吗？所有这些愤怒真的什么也没实现吗？当我们回来时，研究人员将向我们揭示关于病毒式愤怒科学的研究发现。回想一下一个聚会，一个很久很久以前发生的聚会。聚会上的某个人做了一件坏事。也许偷了什么东西。大家必须决定如何处理这个破坏规矩的人。什么都不做，这个违规者可能会再次做坏事。最好惩罚他或把他驱逐出去。千百年来，
humans learned that punishing bad behavior accomplished useful things. It's like evolution placed a bet on that being a good idea for the group. This is Yale psychologist Molly Crocket. Molly says outrage about wrongdoing and the punishments it produced kept people in line. This was good for the group. It also happened to be good for individuals. Our brains evolved to give us a little boost
人类了解到惩罚不良行为能达到有用的目的。这就像进化押注这对于群体来说是一个好主意。这是耶鲁大学心理学家莫莉·克罗克特。莫莉说，对不当行为的愤怒以及随之而来的惩罚让人们循规蹈矩。这对群体有好处。它碰巧对个人也有好处。我们的大脑在进化过程中，会在我们感到愤怒并惩罚某人时
when we get outraged and punish someone. When people decide to punish somebody who's behaved unfairly, we see activation in brain areas associated with reward, including the stratum and the medial prefrontal cortex. In layman's terms, calling out another person's bad behavior feels good. Molly and her team have conducted experiments where they ask volunteers to play the role of a panesher.
给我们一点奖励。当人们决定惩罚一个表现不公的人时，我们会看到与奖励相关的大脑区域被激活，包括纹状体和内侧前额叶皮层。用通俗的话来说，指出别人的不良行为感觉很好。莫莉和她的团队进行了实验，他们要求志愿者扮演惩罚者的角色。
When the volunteer sees something unfair, she can punish the person responsible. Molly says people ask to play the role of panesher, are not only willing to penalize wrongdoers, but to make personal sacrifices in order to do so. For example, in one experiment, the panesisher sees that someone has divided a part of money unfairly rather than share it equitably with another person. I can spend some money to burn your money, and you get sent a message saying that that happened, and you get a final payoff, and you learn how big it could have been if I hadn't burned some of your money. In this rational model of punishment, wrongdoers know they are being punished. In fact,
当志愿者看到不公正的事情时，她可以惩罚责任人。莫莉说，被要求扮演惩罚者的人不仅愿意惩罚做错事的人，甚至愿意为此做出个人牺牲。例如，在一个实验中，惩罚者看到有人不公平地分配了一笔钱，而不是与另一个人公平分享。我可以花一些钱来烧掉你的钱，然后你会收到一条消息，说这发生了，你会得到一个最终收益，并且你会了解到如果我没有烧掉你的一些钱，本可以拿到多少。在这种理性的惩罚模型中，做错事的人知道他们正在被惩罚。事实上，
it is this knowledge that is supposed to act as a deterrent. But Molly and her team asked a deeper question. Would volunteers also be willing to punish transgressors who don't get told they are being punished? The only reason why I would punish you when it's in secret is if I get some personal satisfaction from knowing that you as an unfair person end up with less money. Even when transgressors had no idea they were being punished, when they didn't know how much they would have received otherwise, Molly found that punishers were more than happy to meet justice.
正是这种意识本应起到威慑作用。但莫莉和她的团队提出了一个更深层次的问题。志愿者是否也愿意惩罚那些并不知道自己正在被惩罚的违规者？我在暗地里惩罚你的唯一原因，是因为我知道你这个不公平的人最终得到的钱变少了，这让我获得了一些个人满足感。即使违规者根本不知道自己正在惩罚，当他们不知道自己本来会收到多少钱时，莫莉发现惩罚者仍然非常乐意伸张正义。
There's a sort of visceral satisfaction in doling out punishment, and this is corroborated by the brain imaging evidence which shows that when we decide to punish, we see activation and brain areas associated with reward. Outrage in other words has been so valuable in our revolutionary history that it operates like other important biological functions. It gives us pleasure. But here's the thing, remember the context in which outrage evolved. It evolved in an environment where we interacted with people face to face in small groups, in situations where we're going to repeatedly interact with the same people.
施加惩罚有一种发自内心的满足感，这得到了脑成像证据的证实，该证据表明，当我们决定惩罚时，我们会看到与奖励相关的大脑区域被激活。换句话说，愤怒在我们的进化史上非常有价值，它的运作方式与其他重要的生物功能一样。它给我们带来快乐。但问题是，记住愤怒进化的语境。它是在这样一个环境中进化的：我们在小群体中进行面对面的互动，在我们会与同一个人反复互动的环境中。
In this context, outrage produced benefits, but it also came with costs that prompted people to be judicious about it. If your neighbor, Ag, stalled someone's food and you vented your anger at him, it might feel good, but it could also be dangerous. Aw, could get mad at you, punch you in the throat. You would have to judge when and where and how much it made sense to express outrage. What happens when we take an emotion carefully calibrated for small net groups and give it a global platform? It's not very well equipped for the environment in which we find ourselves now, where the audience is much, much bigger than it traditionally has been.
在这种语境下，愤怒带来了好处，但也伴随着代价，这促使人们对它保持审慎。如果你的邻居阿格偷了某个人的食物，你向他宣泄你的愤怒，这可能会感觉很好，但这也可能是危险的。阿格可能会对你生气，一拳打在你的喉咙上。你必须判断在什么时候、什么地方以及在多大程度上去表达愤怒是合理的。当我们把一种为小团体精心校准的情绪放到一个全球平台上时，会发生什么？对于我们现在所处的环境，即受众比传统情况要大得多、多得多的环境，它并不是很适应。
Now I can be angry at total strangers half a world away. And my physical costs of expressing that outrage close to zero. Given that the psychological benefits are high and the physical costs are low, there are a few checks on outrage anymore. This is why many of us today feel surrounded by outrage. It's nearly impossible to escape. No, no, what's funny is you should be in your pocket. Thousands and thousands of United States veterans have gone into the United States. You never lived a day in my life.
现在我可以对半个世界之外的完全陌生人生气。而我表达这种愤怒的身体代价几乎为零。鉴于心理收益很高而身体代价很低，如今对愤怒的制约已经所剩无几。这就是为什么我们今天许多人都感到被愤怒包围。几乎无法逃脱。不，不，搞笑的是你应该在你的口袋里。成千上万的美国退伍军人已经进入了美国。你一天也没在我的生活中生活过。
It's absolutely a pulp. Are you trying to say that this country does not... Molly has noticed something else. Many of us don't want to escape the vitriol. People on both the right and left revel in it. As a user of social media, one thing that I noticed in my own behavior, particularly after the 2016 elections, was just how much more time I was spending online
这绝对是一派胡言。你是想说这个国家没有……莫莉注意到了另一件事。我们许多人并不想逃离这种尖刻的言论。右翼和左翼的人都在其中狂欢。作为一名社交媒体用户，我在自己的行为中注意到的一件事，尤其是在 2016 年大选之后，是我花在网上的时间多了多少，
and particularly how I felt myself getting sucked into feedback loops where I would read something, I would feel outraged about it, I would feel compelled to share it with my friends, I would then be sort of obsessively checking to see whether people had responded, how they had responded, you know, lather rinse repeat. Every time Molly plugged herself into circuits of outrage, every time she fired off a zinger about President Trump, the ancient circuits in her brain gave her a little reward. Fast forward to early 2017.
尤其是当我感到自己被卷入反馈循环时：我会阅读一些东西，我会对此感到愤怒，我会忍不住与我的朋友分享，然后我会强迫性地查看是否有人回应、他们是如何回应的，你知道的，清洗、冲洗、重复。每当莫莉把自己接入愤怒的电路中，每她对特朗普总统发表一句辛辣的评论时，她大脑中古老的电路就会给她一点奖励。快进到 2017 年初。
President Donald Trump's executive order barring many foreigners, including all refugees from entering the US caused confusion at airports around the world. Travelers have been... The Trump administration began advancing the series of anti-immigration measures. A friend of mine shared an article that the story was about something like the economic benefits of immigrants and how farms in California were seeing tomatoes rot on the vine because they couldn't find enough workers
唐纳德·特朗普总统禁止许多外国人（包括所有难民）进入美国的行政命令在世界各地的机场引起了混乱。旅客们……特朗普政府开始推进一系列反移民措施。我的朋友分享了一篇文章，这个故事是关于移民的经济效益的，比如加州的农场因为找不到足够的工人来收获那些番茄，导致番茄在藤蔓上腐烂。
to harvest those tomatoes. And I read this, I was outraged, I shared it, and then a lot of my friends liked it, and then I got a comment from someone that I didn't even really know that well. And they said the date of this article is 2011. 2011. The president at that time was not Donald Trump, but someone Molly admired.
而我读了这篇文章，我感到很愤怒，我分享了它，然后我的很多朋友都点赞了，接着我收到了一条我甚至不太熟悉的人的评论。他们说这篇文章的日期是 2011 年。2011 年。当时的总统一职并非唐纳德·特朗普，而是莫莉崇拜的人。
Barack Obama. Molly quietly deleted the Facebook post. But the incident was a wake-up call. She looked back on her behavior, how she would get lost in a world of posts, shares, and likes. It was like coming out of a trance and having this realization that time had disappeared and that I had been engaged in a feedback loop, not unlike the apparatus that my PhD lab used to train rats
贝拉克·奥巴马。莫莉默默地删除了这条 Facebook 帖子。但这一事件是一个警钟。她回顾了自己的行为，她是如何迷失在帖子、分享和点赞的世界里的。这就像从 trance（恍惚状态）中醒来，意识到时间已经消失了，而自己一直处于一个反馈循环中，这与我的博士实验室用来训练老鼠按压杠杆以获取可卡因的装置没有什么不同，字面意义上的。
to press leavers to get cocaine, literally. Like, I'm not saying that social media is cocaine, I think they're actually really important distinctions between substance addiction and social media use, and they get conflated a lot in the media. But one thread that they have in common is that both of these processes do seem to tap into our reinforcement learning circuitry in the brain. Most of us underestimate how powerful this brain circuitry can be,
就像，我并不是说社交媒体就是可卡因，我认为物质成瘾和社交媒体使用之间其实有着非常重要的区别，它们在媒体中经常被混为一谈。但它们共同的一个特点是，这两种过程似乎确实触及了我们大脑中的强化学习回路。我们大多数人低估了这种大脑回路有多么强大，
how vulnerable we are to the psychological rewards that come from feeling really, truly mad about something, and then seeing our outrage amplified by others. Social rewards are just as powerful, if not more powerful in driving learning and decision-making, than chocolate or money, right? The approval of our peers is like the most potent reward you can get for social beings like us.
我们对因对某事感到真正、由衷的愤怒，然后看到我们的愤怒被他人放大而带来的心理奖励是多么脆弱。对于像我们这样的社会生物来说，社会奖励在驱动学习和决策方面与巧克力或金钱一样强大，甚至更强大。同伴的认可就像你能得到的对社会生物最强烈的奖励。
Social media platforms take our love for this kind of approval and poor rocket fuel on it. When you share a story with a group of friends in the days before social media, you might not know exactly what they thought of it. You had to watch their faces, and even then, the responses might be ambiguous. But these days? Now we get a count. We can see, oh, 10 friends liked that article I shared. But the one I shared yesterday got 70 likes. So these are signals that we can use to tune our behavior and we have quantified social feedback now in a way that was much more vague before social media.
社交媒体平台抓住了我们对这种认可的喜爱，并为其浇上了火箭燃料。在社交媒体出现之前的日子里，当你与一群朋友分享一个故事时，你可能并不确切知道他们是怎么想的。你不得不观察他们的脸，即便如此，反应也可能是模棱两可的。但现在呢？现在我们有了一个计数器。我们可以看到，哦，有 10 个朋友喜欢我分享的那篇文章。但我昨天分享的那篇获得了 70 个赞。所以这些是我们用来调整行为的信号，现在我们以一种在社交媒体出现之前更加模糊的方式，将社会反馈量化了。
Since humans are smart animals who learn quickly from feedback, we discover that there are very specific ways to get this delicious social approval. My name is Jay Van Bavill, I'm a psychology professor at New York University. Jane and his team have analyzed more than half a million tweets. He has found there is an easy way to dramatically increase likes and retweets. For every moral, emotional word that people use in a tweet, we found that it increased the rate of retweeting from other people who saw it by 15 to 20%. Posts were retweeted 15 to 20% more if people used a moral or emotional word.
既然人类是善于从反馈中快速学习的聪明动物，我们就会发现有非常具体的方法来获得这种美味的社会认可。我叫杰伊·范·巴维尔，我是纽约大学的心理学教授。杰伊和他的团队分析了五十多万条推文。他发现有一种简单的方法可以极大地增加点赞数和转发数。我们发现，人们在推文中使用的每一个带有道德和情感色彩的词，都会使看到它的其他人转发的速度提高 15% 到 20%。如果人们使用了带有道德或情感色彩的词，帖子被转发的几率会增加 15% 到 20%。
The list of words that J&S colleagues defined as moral and emotional is quite long. Curse words are on the list, of course. Some other examples are words like hate, war, greed, punish. J.R.E.R.D. me some sample tweets. So on the topic of same-sex marriage, here's an example tweet from a conservative. Gay marriage is a diabolical evil lie aimed at destroying our nation. And the moral emotional words here are evil and destroying.
杰伊和同事定义为具有道德和情感色彩的词汇列表相当长。脏话当然在榜单上。其他一些例子包括仇恨、战争、贪婪、惩罚等词。杰伊给我举了一些推文的例子。因此，关于同性婚姻这个话题，这里有一条来自保守派的示例推文。同性婚姻是一个旨在摧毁我们国家的恶魔般的邪恶谎言。这里的道德情感词汇是邪恶和摧毁。
And they're both the negative, highly potent words. From a liberal, we have a tweet, new Mormon policy-bans children of same-sex parents. This church wants to punish children, a question mark. Are you kidding me? Shame. You can also generate outrage without using those specific words, of course. You can say, can you believe she said that? Or, what kind of a country do we live in today?
它们都是具有高度潜力的消极词汇。从一个自由派那里，我们有一条推文，新的摩门教政策禁止同性父母的孩子。这个教会想要惩罚无辜的孩子，一个问号。你在开玩笑吗？真可耻。当然，你也可以不用那些特定的词来制造愤怒。你可以说，真不敢相信她说了那样的话？或者，我们今天生活在一个什么样的国家？
J.S. analysis didn't include tweets like that. But even using his more conservative measure, J.Found that moral and emotional words caused messages to spread. And you can, you know, jam a lot of words that have moral emotions in them in a single message and increase the likelihood your message is going to be shared by 60 or 80 or 100%. This outrage often be gets more outrage. Twitter is weird because, you know, there's a level of outrage, then you have people who are outraged about the outrage
杰伊的分析不包括这样的推文。但即便使用他较为保守的测量标准，杰伊发现带有道德和情感色彩的词语也会导致信息传播。而且，你知道的，你可以在一条信息中塞进大量带有道德情感的词汇，从而使你的信息被分享的可能性增加 60%、80% 或 100%。这种愤怒往往会引发更多的愤怒。推特很奇怪，因为，你知道的，存在一种水平的愤怒，然后你会发现有人对这种愤怒感到愤怒，因为这是错误类型的愤怒。
because it's the wrong type of outrage. Then you have people who are outraged about that outrage. And then you have another group of people who are outraged that you're not outraged enough. So you have these four forms of outrage going on at any given time and it just cycles through issue after issue on a 24 hour basis. To be sure, outrage sometimes produces real change. It can bring together marginalized communities.
然后你会发现有人对那种愤怒感到愤怒。然后还有另一群人对你不够愤怒感到愤怒。所以在任何给定的时间，你都有这四种形式的愤怒在发生，它只是在 24 小时的周期内不断循环一个又一个议题。可以肯定的是，愤怒有时确实会带来真正的改变。它可以把被边缘化的社区凝聚在一起。
It can fuel social movements such as the Arab Spring or Black Lives Matter. It can help with elections. Park her up, that's right. Outrage can be especially effective if your goal is to pull someone down. After all, this might be what the emotion was designed for in the first place. Today, Al Franken took to the mic as his political career came crashing down. I will be resigning as a member of the United States Senate. His resignation came after a number of cards coming from his day.
它可以为社会运动注入动力，例如“阿拉伯之春”或“黑人的命也是命”。它可以在选举中发挥作用。停下来，没错。如果你的目标是将某人拉下马，愤怒可能尤其有效。毕竟，这可能正是这种情绪最初被设计出来的目的。今天，阿尔·弗兰肯走上麦克风，因为他的政治生涯轰然倒塌。我将辞去美国参议员职务。他的辞职是在一系列来自他那天的指控之后发生的。
In an apology video posted on Twitter, Kathy Griffin is begging for forgiveness after images of her holding the seven screen news overnight. Kevin Hart stepping down as host this came just days after his name was announced and of course after a firestorm over past anti-gay tweets. Coming up, what outreach does not do well and how to deploy fury more effectively. It can feel good to start a fire.
在推特上发布的一段道歉视频中，凯茜·格里芬在手持七屏新闻过夜的画面流传开来后懇求原谅。凯文·哈特卸任主持人，此前几天他的名字刚刚宣布，当然，在这场关于过去反同推文的风暴之后也是如此。接下来，愤怒不擅长做什么，以及如何更有效地部署狂怒。点燃一把火可能会让人感觉很好。
To see all the push notifications that come to your phone as people like and retweet your outrage. Studies show that the more outrage you demonstrate, the more your message is likely to spread. But psychologist William Brady at Yale says there is a great paradox in the way outrage works. Outrage leads to engagement, but not always to change. The type of people you're getting to that is giving you the shares and the likes. It tends to be people who share your political views, so people have the same political ideology. In other words, Outrage is very effective at spreading a message within an echo chamber.
看到手机上不断弹出推送通知，人们点赞并转发你的愤怒。研究表明，你表现出的愤怒越多，你的消息就越有可能传播。但耶鲁大学的心理学家威廉·布雷迪表示，愤怒运作的方式中存在一个巨大的悖论。愤怒会导致参与，但并不总是能带来改变。吸引到的受众以及给你分享和点赞的人。往往是那些与你政治观点相同的人，也就是具有相同政治意识形态的人。换句话说，愤怒在同温层内部传播信息非常有效。
The use of outrage, the use of moral and emotional language on social media, it really depends on the context in what you're trying to accomplish. If you want to rally the troops, get my people who already agree with me to get interested and to get motivated to act, or is it really to try to persuade others? If your goal is the former, then expressing yourself with moral emotions like outrage can be really effective. If your goal is the latter, then perhaps it's not the best idea. In a study that William is conducted with J. Van Bevel, he found that tweets without
在社交媒体上使用愤怒，使用道德和情感语言，实际上取决于你试图完成什么的语境。如果你想团结队伍，让那些已经同意我观点的人感兴趣并被激励去行动，或者这真的是为了试图说服其他人？如果你的目标是前者，那么用道德情感（如愤怒）来表达自己会非常有效。如果你的目标是后者，那么这可能不是一个好主意。威廉与杰伊·范·巴维尔进行的一项研究发现，没有
a moral and emotional tone were better able to start conversations between people from different political persuasions. In some ways, this makes intuitive sense. When was the last time you changed your mind because someone screamed at you? And that leads to an interesting question. Why do we still see so much outrage, even when we know that it causes the people who disagree with us to tune us out? Aren't those precisely the people whose minds we want to change? Molly Crocket thinks there's a reason beyond our own personal motivations. It has to do with the business models of social media platforms and broadcast outlets.
道德和情感语调的推文更能开启不同政治倾向的人之间的对话。在某种程度上，这在直觉上是说得通的。你上一次因为别人冲你大喊大叫而改变想法是什么时候？这就引出了一个有趣的问题。为什么我们仍然看到这么多的愤怒，即使我们知道这会导致那些不同意我们观点的人将我们屏蔽？难道这些人不正是我们想要改变想法的对象吗？莫莉·克罗克特认为，除了我们自身的个人动机之外，还有别的原因。这与社交媒体平台和广播媒体的商业模式有关。
The goal of the platforms is not the explicit goal of keeping us outrage. It just happens to be that outrage is one way to grab attention and increase engagement. And their goal is engagement and holding our attention as much as possible because that's what's monetized in the business model of the social media platforms. The private benefits of outrage do not flow only to big companies. Increasingly, pundits, commentators, and social media influencers use their visibility to drive advertising,
这些平台的目标并不是明确地让我们保持愤怒。恰巧愤怒是吸引注意力和增加参与度的一种方式。他们的目标是参与度并尽可能多地抓住我们的注意力，因为这正是社交媒体平台的商业模型中能够变现的东西。愤怒的私人利益并不只流向大公司。评论员、时事分析员和社交媒体网红越来越多地利用他们的知名度来推动广告、
book sales, and brand development. There is a new number one atop The New York Times bestseller list, Tucker Carlson, ship a fool and seating Bob Woodward's fear, Trump and the White House. We're motivated to write this book. Well, you know, during the 2016 election, I was noticing the level of anger that was just helpable. Oh yeah! If you haven't ordered it yet or haven't picked it up, make sure you do that. It's a great video.
图书销售和品牌发展。纽约时报畅销书排行榜榜首出现了一个新名字，塔克·卡尔森，《白痴之船》，取代了鲍勃·伍德沃德的《恐惧：特朗普在白宫》。我们写这本书是有动机的。嗯，你知道，在 2016 年大选期间，我注意到那种触手可及的愤怒程度。哦，是的！如果你还没订购或还没买的话，一定要去买一本。这是一本很棒的视频。
Because it's all about what makes it a bit... These private incentives explain why the well-for-outrage runs deep. Why there are new things to be outraged about every hour of every day. While this makes excellent sense for the business models of influencers and their media platforms, Molly says it does not make much sense for the rest of us. It's just constant. There's a constant drip feed of outrage and it makes it hard to know where to focus your efforts. At a certain point, audiences start to become numb. If you were supposed to be angry about one thing on Monday and another on Tuesday,
因为这全关于是什么让它变得有点……这些私人动机解释了为什么愤怒的源泉如此深厚。为什么每小时每天都有新的事情让人感到愤怒。虽然这对于网红及其媒体平台的商业模型来说非常合情合理，但莫莉说，对于我们其余人来说，这并不太合情合理。它只是持续不断的。愤怒不断地一滴一滴地注入，这让人很难知道把精力集中在哪里。在某个时刻，受众开始变得麻木。如果你周一被要求对一件事感到愤怒，周二对另一件事感到愤怒，
by Wednesday, you're exhausted. You may start to tune things out. You can't prioritize what to care about because the volume on everything. It's turned to 11. In the process, things that actually need our attention, where the volume needs to be turned to 11, are drowned out. Careful vetting and investigative reporting today are regularly overshadowed by incendiary opinion. A similar dynamic is playing out in many parts of the world. In Britain, about two-thirds of people say they no longer can tell the difference between rumor and reporting.
到了周三，你已经筋疲力尽了。你可能会开始把这些屏蔽掉。你无法对什么重要进行优先排序，因为每件事的音量都被调到了 11 级（最大音量）。在这个过程中，那些真正需要我们关注的、音量需要被调到 11 级的事情，却被淹没掉了。如今，仔细的审查和调查性报道经常被煽动性的观点所掩盖。世界许多地方正在上演着类似的动态。在英国，大约三分之二的人表示他们再也分不清传言和报道的区别了。
If you're dialing up the volume on all outrage, then it may become more difficult to detect signal in an increasingly noisy public sphere. And this could increase errors that we make in deciding which issues we collectively think are most worthy of our attention and support. support. Mollie Crocket and William Brady are studying whether outrage might also be counterproductive to activists. Does blasting out angry tweets cause some people to feel they have done their part, to forgo the more difficult challenges of protesting in public, driving legislation, or showing up to vote? In other words, can outrage foster slactivism?
如果你把所有愤怒的音量都调大，那么在日益嘈杂的公共领域中，可能就更难探测到信号了。这可能会增加我们在决定哪些议题最值得我们共同关注和支持时所犯的错误。支持。莫莉·克罗克特和威廉·布雷迪正在研究，愤怒是否也可能对活动人士产生反效果？大声发布愤怒的推文是否会使一些人觉得他们已经尽了自己的一份力，从而放弃了在公共场合抗议、推动立法或出面投票等更困难的挑战？换句话说，愤怒会助长“键盘侠主义”吗？
I think that's a genuine worry. I don't think we have the data to know for sure, but it is a possibility and it is something we should worry about, because if you're a certain type of person and maybe you only have enough time to take one action and not do both, then maybe expressing outrage because it is less costly on social media is what you end up doing. And then you don't actually go and you don't actually protest, you don't actually put pressure on legislators like what is really needed to create concrete change. For her part, Julie Zimmerman says her experience has changed the way she feeds off outrage. If you can limit yourself to just those occasional check-ins, a lot of the stories that are wasting people's time have gone away by the next time you sign on.
我认为这是一个真实的担忧。我不认为我们有足够的数据来确切知道，但这是一种可能性，也是我们应该担忧的事情，因为如果你是某种特定类型的人，也许你只有足够的时间采取一种行动而不是两样都做，那么在社交媒体上表达愤怒因为成本较低，可能就是你最后做的事。然后你实际上并没有去，也没有真正去抗议，没有真正向立法者施压，而这才是创造实质性改变真正需要的。就她而言，朱莉·齐默尔曼（Julie Zimmerman）说她的经历改变了她吸收愤怒的方式。如果你能把自己限制在偶尔查看一下，很多浪费人们时间的报道等你下次登录时已经消失了。
She's also decided to refocus her emotional energy. You can stand up and be super outraged about something national, but if you really wanna have an impact, yeah, go pick up litter in the intersection near your house or go, you know, work at an animal shelter. Like there are things that we can do every day that improve our lives and the lives of people around us. But they don't give us that, you know, that drug of having a hot take
她还决定重新聚焦她的情感能量。你可以站起来，对某件国家大事感到无比愤怒，但如果你真的想产生影响，去你家附近的十字路口捡垃圾，或者去动物收容所工作。就像我们每天都可以做一些事情来改善我们的生活和周围人的生活一样。但它们无法给我们那种在社交媒体上传播热门言论的毒品般的快感。
spread around social media. We tell ourselves, well, we're being good citizens, we're keeping up on the news, we're just entertaining ourselves, you know, at great expense to our society. So many tools of modern culture take ancient circuits in the brain and put them in hyper drive. We evolved to need nutrition, but many of us are surrounded by so much food that we now
我们对自己说，嗯，我们是好公民，我们在关注新闻，我们只是在娱乐自己，你知道，代价是我们社会的巨大开销。现代文化的许多工具将大脑中的远古回路推向了极速运转。我们进化出了对营养的需求，但我们许多人周围有太多的食物，以至于我们现在生病了。
get sick. We evolved to care about relationships, but social media has weaponized this, transforming personal connections into metrics of self-worth. Getting angry at wrongdoers was helpful in our revolutionary past, but when people apply that same impulse today on talk radio and Twitter, what we get are doxing and death threats. Our capacity for outrage honed over millennia gives our society guardrails. It tells us how we are supposed to behave and it can lead to positive change.
我们进化出了对人际关系的关注，但社交媒体已经将这一点武器化，将个人联系转化为自我价值的衡量标准。对不法行为感到愤怒在我们的革命过去中是有帮助的，但当人们今天在谈话广播和推特上应用同样的冲动时，我们得到的是人肉搜索和死亡威胁。我们历经数千年磨练出的愤怒能力为我们的社会提供了护栏。它告诉我们应该如何表现，并且可以带来积极的改变。
But used recklessly or for self promotion, outreach can poison the way we interact with each other. It can imprison us in our own echo chambers. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Medural Media is our exclusive advertising sales partner. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Quarelle, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
但如果被鲁莽使用或用于自我宣传，愤怒可能会毒害我们彼此互动的方式。它可能会将我们囚禁在我们自己的回音室里。Hidden Brain 由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。Medural Media 是我们独家的广告销售合作伙伴。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是 Hidden Brain 的执行主编。
Our Ronsang Hero this week is Librarian Will Chase, producing an episode about outrage, involved listening to lots of tape from cable news and talk radio. We relied on Will's looting to uncover some of the tape used in today's program. Thank you Will. For more hidden brain, you can follow us on Facebook, Twitter and at hiddenbrain.org. If you like today's show and like our program, please be sure to share it with a friend. I'm Shankar Vidantam. See you next week. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们本周的无名英雄是图书管理员威尔·蔡斯（Will Chase），制作一集关于愤怒的节目涉及收听大量来自有线新闻和谈话广播的磁带。我们依靠威尔的搜寻来发现今天节目中使用的部分磁带。谢谢你，威尔。想了解更多 Hidden Brain 的内容，你可以在 Facebook、Twitter 以及 hiddenbrain.org 上关注我们。如果你喜欢今天的节目并喜欢我们的栏目，请务必与朋友分享。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。下周见。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。